في بلد بلا دستور مكتوب كاسرائيل تتواصل
المواجهات بينما تريد تغييره حكومه
نتنياهو في النظام القضائي وما تقول
المعارضه انه محاوله لاضعاف القدره
الرقابيه للسلطه القضائيه على السلطتين
التنفيذيه والتشريعيه يتكون القانون
الرئيسي لاسرائيل من مجموعه قوانين اساس
تنظم تقسيم السلطات وحقوق الانسان والحقوق
المدنيه وعند تناقض قانون نقره الكنيست مع
قانون اساس فان الاحتكام يعود للمحكمه
العليا التي تتهم المعارضه نتنياهو
بمحاوله التقويض السلطاتها
التشريعات التي تدفع بها الحكومه تشمل
اربعه بنود هي الحد من المراجعه القضائيه
لتشريعات الكنيست والسيطره الحكومه على
التعيينات القضاه والغاء تدخل المحكمه
العليا في الاوامر التنفيذيه وتحويل
المستشارين القانونيين بالوزارات الى
معينين السياسيين المعارضه تقول ان هذه
التعديلات ستؤدي الى تركيز السلطه
القضائيه في يد السلطه التنفيذيه التي
تسيطر بدورها ايضا على السلطه التشريعيه
بحكم الاغلبيه البرلمانيه
وفقا للكنيست بموجب مشروع القانون لجنه
المكونه من وزير العدل ووزيرين تحدد
الحكومه هويتيهما اضافه الى ثلاثه من
اعضاء الكنيست بينهم رئيس لجنه الدستور
وعضو عن الائتلاف الحاكم وعضو من المعارضه
سيتولون انتخاب القضاه والبته في تعيينهم
ينص مشروع القانون وفقا لما يسمى فقره
التغلب على عدم امكانيه التقاضي بشان
القوانين الاساسيه وان المحكمه بما في ذلك
المحكمه العليا لن تتناول بشكل مباشر او
غير مباشر مساله تتعلق بصحه قانون الاساسي
من القوانين التي تشكل دستور اسرائيل كذلك
يتضمن المشروع التعيين المستشارين
القانونيين في الوزارات مباشره من قبل
الحكومه وان يكون خاضعين للوزراء بدلا من
تبعيتهم للمستشاره القضائيه
وبينما تريد تغييره حكومه اليمين وما تقول
المعارضه انه تركيز مطلق للسلطه بيدها
يبقى الحكم النهائي لما يقوله الشارع في
قادم الايام